hey David I don't think you should ever
cover tulsi gabbard
again she's not gonna be there net
Democratic nominee you were right she's
not even running for re-election in the
House of Representatives just don't talk
about her anymore you've given her
enough coverage this is an interesting
statement because I get people who
contact me angrily saying David why are
you ignoring Tulsi Gabbard and my answer
is I mean I don't answer them but on the
show is I'm not ignoring her I cover her
in proportion to the shot she has at
winning the nomination and in proportion
to how newsworthy the things she does
are I get emails from people who say
David if Tulsi is as irrelevant as you
say you should stop talking about her
well then people criticize me if I do
that when I ignored her I was told that
I'm ignoring the person with the best
progressive platform by some of her
followers so my question to you is
should I continue covering Tulsi Gabbard
should there be any more Tulsi Gabbard
segments because listen I already told
you her politics are not my politics I
don't agree with the way she plays coy
with right-wing ideas I don't agree
there's many disagreements I have with
Tulsi Gabbard I have predicted and I
happen to have been right that she was
either going to be defeated or was going
to bail out of her congressional
reelection under the guise that she's
fully focused on running for president
and it wouldn't be right to run for both
at the same time within 48 hours of me
making that prediction last week she
announced she is not running for
congressional reelection this is a way
some politicians just basically exit
their elected position when they don't
really want to do it anymore they have
something else that they want to do
she's done it should I keep covering
Tulsi Gabbard I am asking you the
question so let me know what you think
respond if you're watching on YouTube
send me a tweet at Dee Pakman write to
me ideally respectfully using the
contact form at david pakman.com when
you click on contact should there be any
more coverage of Tulsi Gabbard and the
question is not so the reason we're
talking about Tulsi is because a lot of
people have been emailing me saying I
either should stop talking about her
together or I should be covering her way
more the same question applies to should
I be covering Amy Klobuchar should I be
covering who Leon Castro like should I
be covering any of the people other than
their debate performances who have
absolutely no shot of securing the
Democratic nomination the same question
applies to all of them the reason we're
talking about Tulsi is people are
actively telling me either cover her
more or don't cover her at all so let me
know what you think